it is possible to imagine you as the
person
who has a resentment towards
a particular world view that you really
worry about
yeah well i've talked i talked to a good
friend of mine last week about that
publicly we'll we'll release it
so i said well do i have a particular
animus against the left let's say
it's like well probably
okay why well
first of all
i'm a university professor
it's not like the universities are
threatened by the right
they're threatened by the left
100 percent and they're not just
threatened a little bit they're
threatened a lot and that threat made it
impossible for me to continue in my
profession the way i was and it cost me
my clinical practice too and that's not
over yet because i have 10 lawsuits
against me out right now from the
college of psychologists
because they've allowed anyone to
complain about me
anywhere in the world for any reason
and have the choice to follow that up
with an investigation which is a
punishment in and of itself and are
doing so
and then i've been tortured nearly to
death
multiple times
by bad actors on the left now i've had
my fair share of
radical right wingers being unhappy with
what i've said but personally
that's been the left the whole time
not only me but my family put it might
put my family at risk in a big way and
constantly like not once or twice
because
many people get cancelled once or twice
but i've been canceled
like 40 times and i know like 200 people
now who've been cancelled and i can tell
you without
doubt that it is one of the worst
experiences of their life and that's if
it only happens once
and so
and then i also know that
the communists killed
100 million people in the 20th century
that the intellectuals excused them for
it non-stop and still haven't quit that
almost no one knows about it and that
the specter of resentful marxism is back
in full force and so do i have a bit of
an animus against that
yes does it go too far
i don't know i'm trying to figure that
out
you